North Korea is issuing a new threat of
military action against the US the state
news agency says Americans should expect
to face an unimaginable strike at an
unexpected time the warning comes just
two days after a North Korean official
said a nuclear war may break out at any
moment
then Tracie is in Beijing with how the
provocative statements may be a response
to naval exercises nearby van good
morning
good morning in this latest threat North
Korea also calls the u.s. and South
Korea war mongers who may start a
nuclear war now this latest threat comes
at a time which appears to be a lull in
North Korea's missile tests the country
has not launched one in more than a
month but North Korea does appear to be
clearly upset about joint military
exercises that the u.s. and South Korea
navies are currently conducting in
waters off the Korean Peninsula this
includes the USS Ronald Reagan aircraft
carrier as well as Navy destroyers now
the US military says these war games are
designed to increase the readiness of
u.s. and South Korean forces but North
Korea sees them as a rehearsal for an
invasion the North says these military
exercises are driving the tension into
the worst line of explosion and prove
the u.s. and South Korea are attempting
to ignite a war on the Korean Peninsula
now the military exercises do end on
Friday but next week the US military is
planning to hold a rehearsal for how
they would evacuate US citizens from
South Korea if a war did break out Jeff
Ben Tracy thank you very much